And the pitch, lined hard deep down the right field line.
It is a fair ball, goes into the right field corner.
Ichiro rounding third; they're gonna wave him.
Here comes the throw home; he's gonna be out.
Safe!
Ichiro couldn't get tagged by Wieters.
He ran around him, reached back for the plate and hit it.
Unbelievable baserunning by Ichiro.
It's a RBI double for Cano.
And the Yankees take a 1-0 lead.
Ichiro went around him, standing up.
Wieters missed the tag.
Now, Ichiro's on the other side of the plate, Wieters had another chance to tag,...
...and Ichiro kind of dodged away from him and put his hand on the plate.
A phenomenal bit of baserunning.